[ __ ] like that's like east coast
goodfellas [ __ ] you don't rat
you don't rat no that's straight across
the board you don't rat which is what's
so funny now all these comics
trashing other comics on social media i
just don't understand that it's just
like what
like you've you've become like comics
already get
[ __ ] why would you go if you don't like
somebody special or you
or whatever you don't like something
that they said
i don't know that's that's a that's a
new uh
phenomenon there's a lot of new
phenomenons this year
and um i don't want to get into it but
let's get into it
no because it's going to deal with stuff
that we don't want to talk about like
cancel culture and whatnot you know what
i mean but in terms of like yeah who
cares people ratting people
out and you know what i mean and it's
been a very a difficult thing
you know i have an snl character idea
it's called twitter lawyer
[Laughter]
yeah twitter lawyer
twitter lawyer do you have any opening
statements
yes your honor i'm all out of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that is the funniest opening statement
to just burning down somebody's life
um but it is it is what it is it is what
it is it is what it is that it's uh
my generation would have been doing the
same thing if we came up on um
on computers and stuff it's a weird sort
of thing you think it's not a
like a new mentality you think it's just
access to um
a keyboard no i think it's the uh
the power of not being face to face
where when i was growing up like there
was a rule
and i agree this is so funny to hear now
but when i was growing up
there was a rule you went to a party or
somebody invited you over you do not
bring up politics and you don't bring up
religion
and then like social media is the
inverse
of that where it's just like everything
you're not supposed to bring up you
bring up
and all rules of common decency
are just out the window and and um
you know the whole hey i can't you know
as a guy growing up there was always
that
you know there was there's that line you
learn where the line is
if i go past that line i'm risking
getting the [ __ ] kicked out of me
and that is sort of um
you know it's like disappeared um it's
funny because like even
i i have to admit like i i've discovered
a couple of comics that i love
that are that could be you know
republicans or whatnot right they're not
out but like
you hear rumors and my initial responses
what is wrong with that i know i know
i'm just
there's nothing wrong with that they're
not out yeah
they're not out as a republican no you
know they did they keep their stuff
private is what i meant yeah because
liberals are out of their [ __ ]
i understand that i understand lord
listen to my [ __ ] point though
okay let me finish my point okay my
initial reaction is like uh
right but it's like no it's i'm just
gonna make up a name it's joey he's a
good guy
you know i mean it's like you know it's
like it has nothing to do with we're
in it this isn't bill
right i just we're in a volatile like i
love how judgmental
the left is you don't know anything
about he's a good guy he's he is still
here
i understand i understand but at the end
of the day it's like
all these even now because of the of
politics and the election all that stuff
like i try not to like let it ruin or
dictate how i feel and what not because
at the end of the day
it doesn't make who you are as a person
you know i mean your political
affiliation
you know we there's good guys everywhere
there's bad guys everywhere
you have a wide variety of people in
your life that's what i'm saying it goes
back to those art rooms where it just
became like it was just
everybody was it's like it was the echo
chamber of it
that i that was what um i found
fascinating to go in and do comedy
in front of like that that like if you
were to graph the people in the room
like it was almost like a
like a straight like there wasn't oh
this guy does this and this person's
over here was just sort of like you know
like uh like a
what do you got like just like all the
dots were like right there right there
yeah yeah
yeah which made it like uh
i don't know it was so easy to get into
trouble
right during your set there because it
was just like there was just one
place where you could store right you
wouldn't have a brian holtzman in
a room like that i mean i would
that's exactly what i would put on i
would i i
would i would film it and yeah but no i
i think
uh you know that's why i watched it i
just find that like that's stuff
fascinating i i try to
you know i definitely you know i joke
about politics and [ __ ] like that but
you know i'm not going to get on
somebody because they're you know
like if you say you're liberal i don't
then think like oh that means that
you're this this i mean there's so many
there's this spectrum of being on the
left is the spectrum of being on the
right you know
and um i don't know i'm kind of hoping
that we
we maybe learned something over the last
20 years
of just you know everybody just [ __ ]
like half the country just [ __ ] on
whoever's i really feel like the first
george bush was the last guy who was
kind of allowed to be president
without half of his country trying to
take him out of office
yeah kind of started with the clinton
lying under oath
about the [ __ ] and then it was bush
stole the election
and obama's not from here and everything
trump did
was just like you know i mean i don't
know how that helps people but
it doesn't it doesn't and i think we're
at a precipice that's why i stopped
giving you [ __ ] bobby
i was just like you know what i need to
bring
the two ghosts together
all right but here's i want to is that
old boy right behind you
yeah oh my god dude i got a horror movie
but for
people at home he told me about this
movie like 10 years ago
and i that one and then the audition
oh my god well i i you invited me to
your birthday party one time
yes and uh i brought you the dvd of old
boy as a gift
yes you did yeah